Після того, як в анексованому Росією Криму сталося одразу кілька надзвичайних ситуацій
на військових та інфраструктурних об'єктах, президент України Володимир Зеленський заявив.
Щодня і щоночі ми бачимо нові повідомлення про вибухи на території, яка тимчасово зайнята окупантами.
Я прошу зараз усіх наших людей в Криму, в інших регіонах на півдні держави,
в окупованих районах Донбасу та Харківщини, бути дуже уважними.
Будь ласка, не наближайтесь до військових об'єктів російської армії і усіх тих місць,
де вони зберігають боєприпаси й техніку, де тримають свої штаби.
На думку німецького політолога Ганса-Геннінґа Шредера, з приходом воєнних дій до Криму –
а саме так можна тлумачити вибухи на російських військових об'єктах – у Кремля виникають дві проблеми.
По-перше, ці події не вписуються в рамки так званої "спецоперації", оголошеної Кремлем.\
У якийсь момент вони мають сказати людям, що це війна, а не спецоперація. А це проблема для населення.
Бої точаться вже пів року, а кремлівське керівництво затято відмовляється називати це війною.
Я думаю, що для тих, хто в цьому бере участь, або для тих, хто когось знає, абсолютно ясно, що це війна.
Тобто руйнується вся конструкція з брехні. Як Кремль із цим впорається, ми ще побачимо.
Друга проблема: Україна дуже чітко дає зрозуміти, що Крим - це українська територія, а не російська.
І це означає, що на майбутніх переговорах - а в якийсь момент ця війна закінчиться -
Україна, звісно, вимагатиме повернення цієї території.
Австрійський політолог Ґергард Манґотт назвав вибухи в Криму "вкрай неприємними" подіями для Кремля,
особливо у світлі ранніх заяв про сакральність Криму, коли Путін називав його "святою землею для Росії".
Обстріли військових об'єктів у Криму демонструють максимальну мету України у війні.
Тобто російські війська мають бути вигнані не лише з територій, які вони захопили після 24 лютого,
а й із територій, окупованих у 2014 році.
Таким чином українці наголошують на своїх законних претензіях на Крим.
І такі успішні удари по російських військових позиціях, звичайно, потрібні українській стороні,
щоб продемонструвати, зокрема, і Заходу: з вашою зброєю та вашими подальшими поставками
ми можемо дати відсіч росіянам, ми можемо завдати їм серйозної шкоди.
Історії успіху завжди дуже важливі для української сторони не лише з огляду на підтримку Заходу,
це також піднімає бойовий дух у їхній власній армії.
А німецький військовий експерт Ґустав Ґрессель в інтерв'ю каналу ZDF
назвав так звані НП в анексованому Криму відвертою ганьбою для РФ.
Це, звісно, ганьба для Росії. Буквального минулого тижня були здійснені атаки українськими балістичними ракетами,
хоча росіяни вихвалялися, що мають зенітні комплекси, які їх запросто можуть збити.
Між "можуть" і "роблять", звичайно, завжди є різниця,  але що вона така велика… Це, звісно, неприємно.
Про це говорять неохоче.
Україна розглядає Кримський міст, що з'єднує окупований півострів з материковою частиною Росії,
як законну військову мету, заявив в інтерв'ю газеті TheGuradian
радник керівника Офісу президента Михайло Подоляк.
Він анонсував "у найближчі два-три місяці" нові атаки на об'єкти в Криму, не підтвердивши при цьому,
чи стоять за вибухами під Джанкоєм і на авіабазі біля селища Гвардійське ЗСУ.
"Наша стратегія - знищити логістику, лінії постачання, склади боєприпасів та інші об'єкти військової інфраструктури.
Це створить хаос у їхніх власних силах", - пояснив він.
Кримський міст Подоляк назвав "незаконним будівництвом та основними воротами
для постачання російської армії в Криму". "Такі об'єкти мають бути знищені", - сказав він.
А ось як оцінює ймовірність атаки на кримський міст ЗСУ австрійський політолог.
Я впевнений, що українська сторона здійснить відповідні спроби у відповідний момент.
Не можна забувати, що до Криму через міст надходить велика кількість військових вантажів,
які потім використовуються на півдні України.
Також руйнація мосту через Керченську протоку, звичайно, стала б абсолютною символічною поразкою
для російського керівництва та російських збройних сил.
Ганс-Геннінґ Шредер бачить також у подіях довкола вибухів у Криму одну з можливостей для України
достукатися таким чином до російського суспільства, оминаючи російську пропаганду.
Українська сторона шукає способи викликати роздратування в російського керівництва та в російському суспільстві.
Сюди належать атаки, акти саботажу, партизанська війна на українській території.
Цю територію українці вважають своєю, і такою її також вважають більшість інших держав.
В надії, що це вплине на російське суспільство.
У соціальних мережах всі бачили кадри цього потужного вибуху на аеродромі в Криму.
Кожному було зрозуміло, що в повітря злетіли боєприпаси, зброя, літаки.
І якщо почитати те, що писали офіційні російські ЗМІ, багато хто просто сміявся...
Якщо російський уряд не зробить розвороту найближчим часом,
він виставить себе на посміховисько за допомогою власної пропаганди.
Як, наприклад, у цьому випадку, коли в Криму на очах у російських туристів українці
явно досягли військового успіху, їм вдалося достукатися до російського суспільства.
Британська розвідка у своєму звіті сформулювала своє розуміння того, що відбувається в Криму, так:
"Причина цих інцидентів і масштаби збитків поки не зрозумілі, але російське командування, швидше за все,
буде дедалі більше стурбоване очевидним погіршенням ситуації з безпекою в Криму,
який є тиловою базою для окупантів" - кінець цитати.